listen if you got caught smoking a joint
down at the beach and what people don't
realize right now is because if you do
this the right way first of all you
should be smoking at the beach you won't
have any problems then but if you are
and a law enforcement officer walks up
on you do not stick that joint your
mouth don't flick the joint into the
water because now you just committed a
felony where before he's probably just
gonna write you a ticket but if he
caught destroying evidence now you're
gonna go to jail really oh yeah so it
takes on a whole new life so there has
to be some smarts used I mean I would
definitely encourage you listen don't
smoke at the beach don't smoke in your
car or do it you know the private place
be responsible yeah um but understand
that even today if they see you vaping
in your car and they decide to pull you
over everything better match you better
have an MMC card
you better be buying from one of the
local you know dispensaries here in the
state of Florida mhm and the cartridges
better all line up or if they don't
they're gonna take that product from you
they're gonna test it if a test positive
for THC um they rescue for a felony
right on the spot
really so again be smart about what
you're doing think about how you're
ingesting your cannabis stay home do it
the right way if they see you on the
road it's gonna create a problem I think
this looks like alcohol we don't want to
be drinking and driving it shouldn't be
smoking and drive and you shouldn't be
smoking and shooting your gun